m.  Peabody, votre scientifique lauréat du prix Nobel
, un explorateur de renommée mondiale,
vous êtes médaillé d'or olympique
au saut en longueur et au décathlon,
vous êtes sûr d'être capable de relever
tous les défis d'élever un
garçon humain, compte tenu de tout ce que je '  ai accompli à quel point
cela pourrait-il être difficile qu'ils adorent
si un garçon peut adopter un chien Je ne vois aucune raison
pour laquelle un chien ne peut pas adopter un garçon l'année prochaine
le chien le plus intelligent du monde pas mal
Peabody fera face à son plus grand défi,
peu importe à quelle distance je pourrais  semble
paternité George Washington quel genre
d'arbre a-t-il coupé George
Washington n'a jamais coupé un cerisier les
gens ont inventé ces histoires pour enseigner aux
enfants une leçon sur le mensonge quelqu'un
connaît vraiment leur histoire hein haletant m.
Peabody Sherman s'est battu aujourd'hui
si les parents de la fille portent plainte, je
veillerai à ce que Sherman soit retiré de
votre garde de façon permanente ce qu'une terre a
provoqué moi un chien oh mon Dieu
tu verras je dois te dire Peabody
où ma fille est concernée  rien
n'est plus important que le jaune bien sûr je vais
répondre à une enquête comment savez-vous tout ce
truc sur George Washington comme c'est gentil
de ne jamais dire à personne ce que je m'apprête
à vous montrer il l'appelle le chemin du retour
où l'avez-vous obtenu  pas où penny
quoi où est penny
Egypte tu utilises le chemin du retour elle y était
allons penny fleur précieuse le Nil
si tu penses que nous allons te laisser
ici tu es définitivement dans le déni je
ne comprends pas
attention Sherman c'est un  piège prendre
le mauvais bateau l'homme paiera non c'est
vrai oh mes trois mots
mr.  Peabody et Sherman
bien Sherman on dirait que nous étions la
cible de cette blague
ne vous moquez
pas